pouvait faire cela 38 les activités
d'éveil remplacé par cette discipline ou
matière bien précises constituent
l'essentiel des nouvelles directives
applicables dès la rentrée prochaine
dans l'enseignement primaire en france
publié aujourd'hui par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
retour donc à une certaine tradition
avec des heures de cours par discipline
introduction de l'étude des sciences et
des nouvelles technologies réapparition
officiels de l'éducation civique pour
expliquer cette réforme
estelle voulzy s'est rendu dans une
école parisienne il arrive à auxerre
maîtriser la langue française c'est la
base de tout l'enseignement le ministre
de l'éducation le rappelle dans ses
textes
l'accent est mis sur la lecture son
enseignement renforcé d'une heure par
semaine les deux premières années
l'écriture un peu oublié revient en
force elle doit être soigné son tracé
précis et appliqué c'est important pour
la rapidité pour les exercices pour tous
c'est chaud venant de savoir écrire sud
afin d'avoir un joli dessin d'écriture
sur évident ne serait ce que pour nous
pour corriger un devoir et même au
niveau des grandes classes si vous avez
voire très mal présentés absolument
dégoûtant à la limite c'est tout juste
si vous avez envie de le corriger
c'est très important si on ne comprend
pas ce qui est écrit les activités dites
d'éveil s'exerceront désormais dans le
cadre de discipline à part entière en
histoire par exemple les recherches
personnelles de documents viendront
enrichir un programme précis respectant
la chronologie
alors quels sont les événements
marquants là quelques et souvenir que tu
en as gardé
ouais le plus marquant c'est surtout
plus restera quand tu as l'impression
que tu as des repères pour connaître la
chronologie l'histoire tellement
l'impression que tu connais les
événements historiques dans l'ordre un
peu près
ça tient vraiment je suis revenu assez
rapidement un certain nombre
chronologique même si je ne faisais pas
toujours par exemple l'histoire en
commençant de la préhistoire jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'eau chaude pourquoi ça vous
paraît trop ambitieux alors ce programme
ambitieux un saut on arrivait à faire un
programme comme ça en deux années et
encore en en limitant à certains faits
très précis vous avait réintroduit ou
introduit cette année aussi l'éducation
civique en très petite quantité
puisqu'elle n'était pas encore au
programme allait aller d'un programme
que la rentrée prochaine
rien sauf une bonne source si on s'en
tient à des choses qu'ils peuvent vivre
et qu'ils peuvent aller au front
vérifier par eux-mêmes par exemple à la
mairie par certaines choses dans
certains services tout à fait
intéressant il explique les nouveaux
programmes entreront en application dès
la rentrée prochaine
pour créer un lien plus étroit entre les
parents d'élèves et l'école
le texte écrit dans un langage clair
sera édité en livre de poche est vendu
en librairie dès le début du mois de mai
c'est signe qu'il n'y aura pas d'heures
supplémentaires de cours qui reste fixé
ses heures à 27 heures par semaine
première